Benim scek 9.0 önceim Corf okulundan
YouTube'un en büyük Jorf kanalına
hepiniz hoş geldiniz. Evet, Zedo
öğretmenleri ile beraber yaptığımız
okula destek kampımızın bugün geldik 23.
gününe. Bugün sizinle beraber 6. üniteyi
afetleri yani baştan sona bu tek videoda
bitireceğiz. Bundan sonra bir de
bölgeler videosu gelecek. Onu da hafta
sonuna yetiştirmeye çalışacağım. Yani bu
video ve bölgeler iki videonuz kaldı.
Hadi bu videoyu bitirdiğimizi
varsayalım. Bir tane videonuz kalmış
oluyor. Bölgeler ve 9. sınıfı bitirmiş
oluyoruz. Evet gençler bu afetleri
atmakta biraz zorlandım çünkü PDF'im
yoktu. Notum hazır değildi. Notumu
yazmakla zaman kaybettim biraz. Bir de
bunun dizgiye gitmesi, gelmesi derken
not biraz zamanımı aldı ama şimdi bunu
tamamladık. Yeni müfredat olduğu için
böyle hafif aksaklıklar olabiliyor.
Notlarımız eksik olabiliyor. Bunları
tamamlamakla uğraşıyoruz. Biraz zaman
kaybedebiliyoruz. Ama merak etmeyin
Zeduava öğretmenleri olarak biz bu yaza
kampa gireceğiz. 10. sınıfa geçeceksiniz
ya siz. Bu yaza kampa gireceğiz. Bütün
notlarınızı, hepsini bu yaza
ayarlayacağız. Eylül'de okulunuz
başladığında hepsi hazır olmuş olacak.
Seneye hiç aksaklık olmadan adım adım
ilerleteceğiz inşallah diyoruz. Hiç
uzatmıyorum. Ben şöyle kalemimi aldım.
Hazırım. Sen de videoyu beğenip abone ol
tuşuna basarak hazandıysan o zaman ne
diyoruz? Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren.
Bir daha asla unutma. Zeduava ile eğitim
her
[Müzik]
yerde. Evet gençler bakın bu bizim Zedua
PDF şablonumuz. Nasıl olmuş? Yani şu
gördüğünüz şey Zedua öğretmenler olarak
biz kendi yayınımızı kurma kararı aldık.
Kendi ayaklarımızın üzerinde durup güçlü
olmaya çalışıyoruz gençler. Sistemde
tutunmaya çalışıyoruz. Zedova
öğretmenleri olarak bu noktada kendi
işte dizgicilerimiz bakın kendi
şablonumuz bunlarla beraber seneye
inşallah bir öğretmen yayını olarak
karşınıza çıkacağız. Şu anda kendi
yayınımızın şablonunu aktardım
notlarımı. Bu notları siteye yükledim.
siteden zeduva.com sitesinden aynı bu
şekilde indirebilirsiniz diyorum ve
derse başlayalım. Şimdi gençler konumuz
afetler. Bu afetlerin daha basit bir
kısmını bu derste öğreneceksiniz ama bu
afetlerle alakalı çok daha ayrıntısı 10.
sınıfın son ünitesinde. Orada tsunami
nedir, deprem nedir, işte heyelan nedir?
Orada ayrıntılı anlatacağız. Burada çok
daha genel geçer kısmını öğrenmenizi
istiyor Map sizden. Mesela ne? Map diyor
ki bize bu konuda öğrenci tehlike, risk
ve afet nedir? Bunu bilsin ve bunlar
arasında nasıl bir ayrım olduğunu
anlasın. Yani tehlike, risk, afet nedir?
Şuradaki ilişkiyi bilmenizi istiyor
sizden. Bunu da ben size bir örnekle
anlatacağım. Örnek sonrasında bunların
tanımlarına bakarız. Ama önce bir bunun
farkı ne? Bunu öğrenmen lazım. Bak şimdi
tehlike, risk, afet. Tehlike ne biliyor
musun? Mesela bir dağ var. Bu dağın
bulunduğu yerde toprak kayabilir. Bak bu
bir tehlike. Ya da Türkiye, Türkiye'de
fay hatları var değil mi? Fay hatları
olduğu için Türkiye'de Türkiye'de deprem
olabilir. Bu bir tehlikeyi ifade ediyor.
Şimdi bir tane dağımız var. Burada
toprak kayabilir. Tamam bu tehlike. Ama
buraya gelip insanlar ev yaptığında,
insanlar yol yaptığında, işin içine
artık insanları soktuğumuzda ya da başka
bir şeyleri, başka canlıları vesaire
soktuğumuzda iş artık risk kısmına
gidiyor. Biz orada o arazide tarım
yaptığımızda riske dönüşüyor. Anlaştık
mı? Mesela bir daha baştan alayım.
Buradaki bu ayrımı oturtmak biraz zor
oluyor. Bir tane dağımız var. Burası
heyelan bölgesi, toprak kayması bölgesi.
Burada toprak kayması bölgesi olduğu
için burası tehlike kısmına giriyor. Ama
bu toprak kayması bölgesinde ben bir ev
yaptığımda, ben burada işte yol yapmaya
kalktığımda, tarımı oluşturduğumda,
tarım arazisi yaptığımda bu artık riske
dönüyor. Risk oluyor. Afet ne oluyor?
İşte o bölgedeki o toprağın kayması,
insanların canlarına ve mallarına neden
olması, can ve mal kaybına neden olması
da afete dönüşmesine neden oluyor.
Buradaki mantığı anladık mı? Mesela bunu
daha hani belki bu afet üzerinden
anlayamayabilirsin. Evinden anlatayım
sana. Mesela ocağın üzerine tencereyi
koydun. Tamam mı? Ateşi de açtın. Ateşi
açtın. Tencere kaynıyor. Tamam mı?
Burada bir tehlike var. Tamam. Neden? E
çünkü ateş var orada. İşte ocağın
üstünde bir tencere var. Ateş yanıyor.
Bir tehlike var. Bakın. He burası
tehlike. Riske dönüşmedi bak. Tehlike.
Ama o ateşin yanına ben bir kağıt
getirdiğim zaman yakınında bir de kağıt
olsa. He bak bu sefer riske dönüşmeye
başlıyor. O kağıt ateşten alev alabilir.
Bak risk oluşmaya başlıyor. Aynı heylan
bölgesinde insanın yaşaması gibi düşün.
Şimdi o kağıt ateşin yamacında yanında
duruyor. Risk ha o kağıt gelip ateşle
beraber temas edip yangın çıkarttığı
zaman birçok yer yandığında, düşün ev
yandığında o zaman afete dönüşmüş
oluyor. Buradaki mantığı anladın mı?
Tehlike, risk ve afet arasındaki bu
ilişkiyi böyle bilmen lazım. Anlaştık
mı? Peki hocam afet dediğimiz şey ne?
Bak çok basit. Bu tanımı ezberlemene
gerek yok. Dikkatli dinle. Bak
insanlara, diğer canlılara ve çevreye
zarar veren olaylara afet diyoruz. Afet
olması için ne olması gerekiyormuş?
Zarar verecek insanlara, diğer
canlılara, çevreye zarar veriyor. Bir de
bu gençler hayatın olağan akışının
dışında olacak. Çok ciddi can ve mal
kayıplarına neden olacak. Deprem değil
mi? Bakın burada depremler, heylanlar,
şurada depremler, selve ve taşkınlar,
heylanlar, çığlar, bunlar afet. Bizim
ülkemizde bakın deprem kuşağındayız. Bu
deprem kuşağında olmamızın sonucunda
afetlere rastlıyoruz. En yakın zamanda
mesela ben Silivri'de oturuyorum.
Silivri'de 6.2 büyüklüğünde deprem oldu.
Değil mi? Risk çok arttı burada mesela.
Evet. Tehlike, risk ve afetin mantığını
anladık mı? Şöyle bunun diyagram
halindeki bunu da mantığını anlatmaya
çalışayım size. Bakın şu bölge tehlike
bölgesi. Görüyor musunuz? Şu bölge
tehlike bölgesi. Yani bir heyelan alanı
var. Şu bölge, heylanın bulunduğu bütün
bölge tehlike bölgesi. Ama insan gelmiş
şuraya, şuraya bir tane risk alanı
oluşturmuş. Bakın hatta şurayı da
içerisine alıyor. Şurası risk alanına
dönüşmüş. Bunu mavi çizeyim şöyle.
Burası risk alanı. İnsanlar içerisine
girmiş oranın yol yapmış, tarım yapmış
gibi düşünün. Ha bu risk alanının da
hepsi afete dönüşmemiş. Bu riskin de
şuradaki bölgesi, bakın şuradaki
bölgesinde bir heylan olmuş. Toprak
kaymış. O bölgesi afete dönüşmüş.
Anlaştık mı mantığı? Tamam. Afet, risk
ve tehlikenin ilişkisini örnekle beraber
açıklayınız. Bu soru büyük bir ihtimalle
sınavda karşına çıkacak. Tamam. Evet.
Şöyle bakın. Dünyadan örnekler vermiş
bize. Dünyadaki tsunamilerden, dünyadaki
depremlerden vesaire örnekler vermiş.
Ama sen şimdi bunları tabii ki
bilemezsin. Önce afetleri bilmemiz
lazım. Ondan sonra bunların ne olduğunu
bileceksin. Mesela bakın şu gördüğünüz
afetler. Biz afetleri ikiye ayırdık. Ne?
Doğa olayları sonucu oluşan afetler.
Şöyle doğal olayları. Bir de beşeri
faaliyetleri sonucu oluşan afetler. Biz
zaten 9. sınıfta her şeyi dikkat edin.
Neye ayırıyoruz? İkiye ayırıyoruz
genelde, değil mi? Doğal, beşeri. Doğal
çevrede olanlar, insan etkisiyle olanlar
beşeri diyoruz. İşte MAP bizden şu an ne
istiyor biliyor musunuz? Diyor ki bu
öğrenci 9. sınıfta sadece şu tabloyu
bilsin. Yani şu tablodan kastımız şu
yani afetleri ayırabilsin. Hangisi
jeolojik, hangisi jeomorfolojik, hangisi
işte klimatolojik, meteorolojik, hangisi
insan kaynaklı. Sadece bu tabloyu
bilmenizi istiyor. Bu tablodaki depremi,
tsunamiyi, volkan patlamasını bilmenizi
istemiyor. Bu sene 9. sınıf için bunu ne
zaman öğreteceğiz size? Seneye 10.
sınıfın sonunda öğreteceğiz. Ama bu sene
sadece şunu anlatmakta mantıksız sana.
Yani düşünsene ben sana diyeceğim ki
şimdi deprem ve tsunamiyi jeolojik
jeomorfolojik afetlere koyuyoruz. E sen
depremin ne olduğunu bilmiyorsun ki.
Tsunaminin ne olduğunu bilmiyorsun ki.
Nasıl o zaman bunu yerleştireceğiz
buraya? İşte o yüzden ben sana çok da
ayrıntılı olmadan ama depremin ne
olduğunu, tsunaminin ne olduğunu, çok
kısaca, kabaca dünyada nerede
görüldüğünü kabaca göstereceğim ki sen
depremin ne olduğunu bil ki onu buradaki
tabloya koyabilelim. Anlaştık mı? O
yüzden önce sana deprem, tsunami gibi
afetleri anlatacağım şimdi. Çünkü bunlar
havada kalıyor. Biliyorum öğretmenin de
derste anlattığında havada kalıyor.
Havada kalmasın diye. Önce sana bunları
anlatacağım kabaca. Bütün bilgileri
bilmene gerek yok. Çünkü bu bilgiler
seneyenin bilgisi. Ama ne olduğunu
anlatacağım sana. Ondan sonra geleceğiz
dersin sonunda bu tabloya
yerleştireceğiz. Mantığını oturtacağız.
Anlaştık mı? Map biraz bunu yaparken, bu
konuyun dizilimini yaparken açıkçası
biraz hata yaptı. Depremler gençler.
Depremler nasıl oluşuyor biliyor
musunuz? İlk önce mantığını öğrenin.
Hani içeride bir çekirdek var. Dünyanın
içinde bir çekirdek var ve bu çekirdek
üstünde magma var, manto var. Bu mantoyu
sürekli ısıtıyor. Çünkü çekirdek 6.000
derecelerde. Bu üstündeki mantoyu
sürekli ısıtıyor gençler. Ve ısınan
manto bir çorba kaynayınca ne olur?
Yükseğe çıkar. Ve çorbanın üstünde
kabarcıklar oluşur. Hatırlıyor musun?
Çorbayı bir düşün. Çorba kaynayınca
çorbanın üstünde kabarcıklar oluşur.
Aynı şey oluyor. Ne oluyor? O iç
çekirdek çekirdek kaynatıyor üstündeki
mantoyu ve o manto biraz daha akışkan
sıvı halde kaynayıp çorba gibi yukarı
çıkıyor. Yukarı çıkınca da gençler e
bizim şu an yer küre var değil mi? Yer
var. Yer kabuğu var. Yer kabuğuna
çarpıyor ve bu yer kabuğunda bu levha
diyoruz biz bunlara. Yer kabuklarını
yani kıtaları diyelim biz buna. Öyle
anla. Kıtaları birbirinden ayırıyor.
Bakın çarpıyor. Bu kıtaya çarptı.
Kıtaları birbirinden kırdı. Burayı
kırdı. kırık oldu ve kıtaları
birbirinden ayırmaya başladı. Hah bak
burada kırık oldu. Görüyor musun? İşte
bu kırık dediğimiz yer fay. Fay
dediğimiz yer deprem demek. İşte bu
deprem olan yerler aslında kırık
hatları. Nasıl oluştu kırık hatları?
Alttaki magmonun magmaın magma magmaın
yükselip kıtaları birbirinden
ayırmasıyla oluştu. İşte bu deprem
alanlarında buralar kırık hattı. Buralar
fay hattı. E burası kırılırsa buradan
dışarı lav çıkar. E o zaman volkanlar da
burada olur değil mi gençler? Dünyadaki
depremler, dünyadaki volkanlar aynı
yerdedir. Aynı çizgilerdedir. Aynı fay
hatlarında görülür. Aynı zamanda sıcak
sular da böyledir. Neden? Burası kırıldı
ya. E buradan aşağıya sular sızdı.
Aşağıda ısındı. Yüzeye çıktı. E ne
olacak? Sıcak sular depremlerle
paralellik gösterecek. Tamam. O yüzden
dünyadaki deprem çizgisini buradaki
birçok bilgiyi şu an bilmeyeceğiz seneye
sadece kabaca. Dünyadaki deprem
çizgisini bilmen lazım. Ben de bunu sana
diğer notumda dünya haritasını açayım.
Orada göstereyim. Şimdi bakın, dünya
deprem hattı nereden geçer? Bu dünya
deprem hattını çizmeyi bilmeniz lazım
gençler. Eğer bilemezseniz bu dünya
deprem hattını çizmeyi o zaman sorun
yaşarız. Neden? Sen şimdi dünya deprem
bölgelerini bilirsen dünyada deprem
nerede olur? Dünyada volkanlar nerede
olur? Dünyada sıcak sular nerede olur?
Dünyada kaplıcalar nerede olur? Hepsi
aynı şey. Bunu bilirsen hepsini yorum
yapabileceksin. Gençler şu Amerika
kıtasını görüyor musunuz? Bu Amerika
kıtasının karşınıza bir tane boş bir
tane harita alın gençler. Kitapların
arkasında olur ya. O haritayı beraber
çizelim. Bak bu Amerika kıtasının
batısını boydan boya çiziyorum. Gördünüz
mü? Bu bölge deprem bölgesi. O zaman bu
bölge volkanik patlamaların olduğu
bölge. O zaman bu bölge sıcak su
kaynaklarının bulunduğu bölge. Levha
sınırları buralar demek. Devam ediyorum.
Benimle beraber çiz. Önüne bir tane
harita al. Çiz. Geldim. Şu Avrupa'nın
ortasından geliyorum. Bakın Türkiye'den
geldim. Şuradan Himalayalardan geldim.
Endonezya'dan Yeni Zelanda'ya ulaştım.
Şöyle biraz küçülteyim. Göremedin.
Buradan Endonezya'dan Japonya'ya doğru
gittim. Gördün mü? Tamam. Bir de bakın
Afrika'nın doğusunda böyle bir kırık var
burada. Gördünüz mü? He hocam o zaman
bir de Afrika'nın doğusundan buradan
Türkiye'ye geldim. Birleştirdim bu hat.
İşte bunlar dünyadaki depremlerin olduğu
yerler. Bir tane daha var. Onu maviyle
alıyorum. Neden? Çünkü o okyanusun
ortasında. Bakın şuradan okyanusun
ortasından şuradan İzlanda'ya gidiyor.
Gördünüz mü? Bir kere daha çiziyorum
sizinle beraber. Bu çok önemli bir bilgi
gençler. Şöyle benimle beraber çizsen de
Amerika'nın batısını boydan boya çizdim.
Şöyle Avrupa'nın ortasından Türkiye'den
Endonezya'dan Yeni Zelanda'ya buradan
Japonya'ya. Afrika'nın doğusundan
Türkiye'ye doğru çizdim. Sonra Atlas
Okyanusundan İzlanda'ya doğru çizdim. Bu
dünyadaki depremlerin bulunduğu
bölgeler, dünyadaki volkanların olduğu
yerler. Buralar levha sınırları. Buralar
aynı zamanda sıcak su kaynaklarının
bulunduğu bölgeler. Anlaştık mı? Geçelim
notumuza. Şimdi bu depremler, depremlere
örnekler, depremlerin başlıca etkileri
kısmını size göstermiyorum. Yani
depremden önce olacaklar, sonra
olacaklar. Bunlar seneyenin konusu
gençler. Şu an sen kabaca depremin ne
olduğunu öğrendin mi? Öğrendin. Neden
öğretiyorum sana? Çünkü ben sana
diyeceğim ki bak şimdi diyeceğim.
Depremi jeolojik ve jeomorfolojik
afetler içerisinde değerlendiriyoruz
diyeceğim sana. Değil mi? Neden
jeolojik, jeorfolojik? Sen düşüneceksin
şimdi. Hocam, nereden geliyordu deprem?
Az önce gördüm. Yerin altındaki güçten
geliyordu. E hocam o zaman jeolojik,
jeomorfolojik, jeoyer, jeoer yerden
geliyor. O zaman jeolojinin içine
koyarım. Ama sen depremin nasıl
oluştuğunu bilmezsen, depremin ne
olduğunu bilmezsen nasıl getirip bunu
jeolojik jeomorfolojiye koyacağız? Şimdi
o zaman bu tabloyu sadece ezberlemiş
olacaksın. O zaman mantığıyla
öğrenememiş olacağız. O yüzden
mantığıyla öğrenebilmen için bunu önce
sana afetleri gösteriyorum. Depremi
öğrendik mi? Tamam. Diğeri tsunami.
Tsunamiyi nasıl aklına getireceksin?
Bakın, dalgaların metrelerce olup karaya
gelmesi. Tsunami değil mi? Tu su geliyor
diyeceksin. Tsunami. Tü su geliyor. Aman
Allah'ım diyeceksin. Tü su geliyor.
Suyun gelmesidir tsunami gençler. Suyun
metrelerce yüksek olup karayı basmasına
tsunami diyoruz. Tamam mı? Tsunaminin
mantığını anladın mı? Tsunaminin nasıl
oluştuğu bizim için önemli bu derste.
Tsunami gençler depremlerle, volkanik
patlamalarla ve heyelanlarla bağlantılı.
Nasıl yani hocam? Şöyle, tsunami
oluşabilmesi için, o dalgaların kabarıp
karaya vurması için denizde deprem
olması gerekiyor. Ya da deniz altında
volkan patlayacak. Volkanın patlaması
gerekiyor. Çünkü denizde bir deprem
olduğunu düşünün. Deprem oldu denizde.
Denizde bir kabarma oluşturdu ve karaya
vurur. Ya da denizin altında bir volkan
patlaması oldu. Ne olacak? denizin
kabarmasına neden olup gidip karaya
vurmasına sağlayacak. Yani aslında biz
tsun tsunamiyi bakın şurada klimatolojik
meteorolojinin içerisine koymuyoruz.
Neyin içerisine koyuyoruz tsunamiyi?
Deprem gibi jeolojik jeorfolojik afetler
içerisine koyuyoruz. Ve bu konunun en
önemli noktası burası. Tsunami diyorsun
çünkü su geliyor. Hocam o zaman bu
meteorolojik, klimatolojik gibi geliyor
sana. Su geliyor yani dalga geliyor.
Hayır. Demek ki tsunamiyi oluşturan şey
ne? Deprem, volkanik patlamalar ve
heylanlar. Bunların hepsi nereden
geliyor? Yerden geliyorlar. E yerden
jeolojik bir şey. He tsunamiyi oluşturan
o nedenler jeolojik ve jeomorfolojik
olduğu için tsunamiler jeolojik
jeomorfolojik afetler içerisine koyulur.
Anlaştık mı? Şimdi ben sana ne
yapıyorum? Bak dikkat et. Meb'in bizden
istediğini yapıyorum. Map bana diyor ki
Yunus hoca diyor sen şu tabloyu
öğreteceksin çocuğa diyor. Ben de sana
kabaca depremi gösterdim. Bu depremin
neden jeolojik jeorfolojik afet olduğunu
ezberlemeden mantıken gösterdim sana.
Şimdi düşüneceksin hocam. Tsunami
jeolojik mi jeorfolojik mi? He tsunami
deniz kabarıyor ama yerden gelen güçle
kabarıyor. Ha hocam yerden geldiği için
jeoyer jeoyer. J yerin içerisine
koyacağım tsunamiyi. Anlaştık mı? Diğeri
bakın volkan patlamaları. Ha bu arada
tsunamilere nerede rastlayacağız biz?
Tsunamilere depremlere yakın olması
gerekiyor tsunami tsunami bölgelerinin.
Neden? E çünkü deprem olacak da deniz
kabaracak. Demek ki tsunamilerle
depremler arasında da bir bağlantı var.
Diğeri tsunamiler. Volkanizma. E
volkanik patlamalar depremlerle
bağlantılı. O zaman volkanik patlamalara
ben nerede rastlayacağım? Az önce
çizdiğimiz deprem hatlarında
rastlayacağım. Anlaştık mı? Yani
volkanizma nereden geliyor hocam? Hemen
gelelim buradaki çizelgemize, tablomuza.
Evolkan patlamaları da hocam depremlerle
bağlantılı yerden geliyor. Gücünü yerden
alıyor. O zaman jeoyer, jeoyer,
jeolojik, jeomorfolojik afetler altına
koyacağız. Tamam mı? Şimdi bakın
gençler, size bir şey göstermek
istiyorum. Şu harita benim size az önce
gösterdiğim haritadan biraz farklı.
Nasıl farklı? Neden farklı? Dünyanın
biraz daha arkasından alınmış bir harita
bu. Dikkat edin bakın. Avustralya batıya
kaymış. Amerika bu buraya kaymış.
Normalde biz Avustralya'yı şurada şurada
görüyorduk. Biraz tersten bir harita bu.
Niye bu haritayı kullanmış burada Milli
Eğitim Bakanlığı? Çünkü şu Amerika'nın
batısına ben sana bir tane deprem hattı
çizmiştim. Hatırlıyor musun az önce? Bak
şöyle çizeyim. Amerika'nın batısını
boydan boya çizeceksin demiştim sana.
Çizdim. Bir de şuradan hani Himalaya
dağlarından gelip Endonezya'dan, Yeni
Zelanda'ya bir de buradan Japonya'ya
doğru uzanan bir hat çizmiştim sana.
Neden bunu böyle tersten almışlar? Şu
hat var ya bakın şuradan. Görüyor
musunuz? Amerika'nın batısına doğru
uzanan bir hat var. Bu gençler aslında
şöyle bir hat. Burası Pasifik ateş
çemberi. Dünyadaki en fazla depremlerin
olduğu, en fazla volkanik patlamaların
olduğu, yani yerden gelen gücün en fazla
etkin olduğu Pasifik ateş çemberi
burası. Bu Pasifik ateş çemberini sana
en güzel şekilde ancak bu haritada
gösterirler. Çünkü Amerika'nın batısıyla
burası normalde çok uzak birbirinden.
Normaldeki haritada ta burada orası.
Orada pek anlayamıyorsun birleşik
olduğunu ama diğer bu haritadan bakınca
buradaki mantığı kavrıyorsun. Pasifik
ateş çemberini sana göstermek için
yapıyor bunu. Tamam. Volkanizmayı da
gördük mü? Bakın şurada volkanizma
faaliyetinin etkileri vesaire. Bunlara
girmiyorum. Bunlar 10. sınıf konusu.
Geldim buraya. Kütle hareketleri.
Heylan. Bakın şöyle. Heylan ne demek
biliyor musunuz gençler? Heylan. Hey
şöyle kodlayacaksın kafanda. Hey lan
gelme bak. Heye lan. Hey lan gelme.
Dağın bakın yarısı kopuk gelmiş. Yarısı
kopmuş. Dağın yarısı kopmuş. Gelmiş. Biz
de ne diye bağırıyoruz? Hey lan gelme.
Nasıl? Hey lan. Heye lan. Hey lan gelme.
Şuraya iyi bak. Görsele. Heylan
dediğinde bu gelecek aklına. Dağın
yarısının kopup gelmesi. Gençler nasıl
kopup geliyor bu heyelan? Toprak arazi
eğimli ya. Su bir de yağmur var. yağmur
suyu alıyor, alıyor, alıyor, alıyor,
alıyor, alıyor, alıyor ve dağın yarısı
kopup geliyor. Heylan dediğinde aklınıza
bu gelecek. Tamam mı? Heylan. Ha heylan
gelme. Devasa bir dağın kopup gelmesi
diyeceksin. Peki bu nasıl oluştu?
Heylan. Bunu nereye koyacağız
tablomuzda? Jeolojik jeorfolojik. Şuraya
koyacağız bakın. Jeolojik jeomorfolojik.
Yani bu jeomorfolojik bir afet. Neden?
eğimli arazilerde görülüyor. Dağın
yarısı kopuk geliyor. Jeolojik yerle
alakalı, yer şekilleriyile alakalı
heylan. Bunun da mantığını anladık mı?
Tamam. Kaya düşmesi Türkçe. Bunu
bilirsin. Eğimli arazilerde bak yine
jeolojiyle, jeomorfolojiyle alakalı.
Eğimli arazilerde kayaların parçalanıp
düşmesi. Türkçe olduğu için bunu bunun
altına koyabilirsin. Sorun yok. Çamur
akıntıları yine aynı. Eğimli arazilerde
jeolojiyle, jeomorfolojiyle, yer
şekliyile alakalı. Deyimli arazilerde
çamurun akıp gelmesi. Bakın ne yaptık
şimdi. Jeolojik, jeomorfolojik afetleri
gördük. Buradaki mantık ne biliyor
musun? MB'in bizden istediği ne? Diyor
ki M tehlikeyi, riski ve afeti öğren.
Bunları karşılaştırmayı bil. Örnekle
beraber bunları karşılaştır diyor.
Birinci sorumuz. İkinci sorumuz da bu.
Buradaki afetleri bu tablo biçiminde
tabloya yerleştirebilir. Sana böyle bir
tablo verip öğretmenim bunları
yerleştirmeni isteyebilir. Ya da der ki
jeolojik jeomorfolojik afetlere örnekler
ver. der sana ya da çeşitli afetler
verir sınavda. Bunların bu gruplardan
hangisine girdiğini söyle. İşte
jeolojik, jeomorfolojik diye yazarsın
gibi. Anlaştık mı? Şimdi gelelim
meteorolojik klimatolojik afetlere. Bak
meteoroloji hava durumuydu. Hani
meteorolojiden alınan hava olay hava
durumuna göre şöyle yarın yağmur
yağacak, yarın kar yağışı olacak.
Klimatolojik diyor bak. İklim, havayla
alakalı olacak bunlar. E bak Selve
taşkınlar. Öyle değil mi? Selve taşkın.
Yağmur yağdı. Dere yatakları buna
dayanamadı. Hop. Selve Taşkın oldu.
Neyle? Havayla alakalı bir şey. Klima
havayla eee iklimle alakalı bir şey.
Selve Taşkın kuraklığa bak. Kuraklık
neydi? E hocam suyun olmaması,
buharlaşıp gitmesi. Bunları size tek tek
az önceki gibi aşağıya çekip
anlatmıyorum. Çünkü bunlar biraz daha
Türkçe anlayabileceğimiz şeyler.
Kuraklık, su yok, buharlaşma. Ha,
havayla alakalı, klematoloji,
meteorolojiyle alakalı deyip
meteoroloji, klematoloji afetlerinin
altına koyacaksın. Çığı nedir? Çığı ne
var? Dağımız var. Kar yağdı. Yağdı,
yağdı, yağdı. İşte çevreden gürültü
oldu, oldu, bu oldu. Ve dağdaki karlar
bir anda kaydılar gittiler. Çığ. E nasıl
olacak? Meteorolojik hava olayları, hava
durumuyla alakalı bir şey değil mi? Kar
yağmasa, kar olmasa nasıl çığ olsun?
Başka? Bir diğeri fırtına, kasırga,
hortum. Fırtına, kasırga, hortumu sana
göstermem lazım. Çünkü o önemli. Çığı,
kuraklık, sel ve taşkını anlarsın.
Fırtına, kasılga, hortumu
anlayamayabilirsin. Bakın gençler tekrar
hatırlatıyorum. öğretmeninize lütfen
öğretmeniniz size bu kuraklık nedir?
İşte sel ve taşkınlar nedir? Bu sel ve
taşkın depremlerle alakalı soru sorarsa,
bunları böyle ayrıntılı anlatmaya
kalkarsa, bunun böyle olmaması
gerektiğini söyleyin. O 10. sınıfın
konusu. Biz şu an sadece bunların
tablolamasını öğreniyoruz. Gelelim şimdi
şiddetli rüzgar. Bak fırtına, kasırga,
hortum. Gençler bunlara tropikal
siklonlar da deniyor. Bunlar dünyada
nerede görülüyor? Bunu göstereyim. Size
hep bunu bilin. Bunlar çok şiddetli.
saatte 120 km hızlara ulaşıyor. Amerika
haberlerinde duyuyorsunuzdur. Mahvediyor
oraları. Nasıl oluşuyor biliyor musunuz?
Şu ekvator bölgesinde bir enerji
birikimi var. Şuradan gelen Alize
rüzgarları burada dönerek saparak
geliyor bu Alize rüzgarları saparak
gelen bu Alize rüzgarları burada enerji
birikimi ile beraber bunu göstermiştik
size aslında tropikal siklonları değil
mi? Hatırlıyorum. Şöyle kıtalara,
karalara vuruyor. Bakın şu bölgeye
vuruyor. Aynı şekilde buradan geliyor
Alize. Hoppa şurada Hindistan'a, Çin'e
doğru vuruyor. Ve şu kısımda da
Avustralya'ya, şu kısma ulaşıyor. Bu
tropikal rüzgarların, hortumların
haritasını bilelim. Peki bunlar neyle
alakalı? Jeolojik, jeomorfolojik mi?
Hayır. Nasıl? Meteorolojik,
klimatolojik. Şu an ne yaptık biz? Bakın
ne yaptık? Jeolojik, jeorfolojik,
meteorolojik, klimatolojik bütün hepsini
sıraladık. Bu tarafa geliyorum. Bitmedi.
Ama bakın doğal afetler içerisinde
ayrıca ne var? Bir de biyolojik olanlar
var. Şöyle biyolojik olanlar var.
Erozyon. Bu önemli. Rica ediyorum burada
dikkatli dinle. Erozyon demeyeceğiz biz
buna hiçbir zaman. Ne diyeceğiz biliyor
musun? Erozyont diyeceğiz. Bak hey
denildiğinde ne yapıyordun? Heylan
gelme. Dağın yarısının kopup gelmesi.
Suya şişti şişti. Emli arazi kaydı
geldi. Tamam. Heylan erozyont. Bak
erozyon yok. Ne diyeceksin? Erozyont
gençler kurak bir arazi var. Kurak.
Burayı böyle çöl gibi düşünün. Güneydoğu
Anadolu, İç Anadolu bölgesindeyiz. Kurak
bir arazi gözünüzün önüne getirin. Yunus
burayı kes kes. Buraya bir tane kurak
arazi koy. Kes burayı kes kes. Şuraya
bir tane resim koyayım. Bakın şimdi bu
kurak araziyi görüyorsun. Burada bitki
var mı? Yok. Burada arazi çıplak.
Arazinin üstünde bir şey yok. Böyle
olunca ne oluyor biliyor musunuz? Rüzgar
esiyor, rüzgar geliyor. Yağmur yağıyor.
Bu toprağın üstündeki ince yapılı
kumları alıp götürüyor. Bak eroz yont
yapıyor. Eroz yont. Toprağın üstünü
yontuyor. Kocaman bir dağ alıp
götürmüyor. Bak ikisi başka şeyler.
Buraya bak. Kurak bir arazi. Rüzgar
toprağın üstündeki o e küçük parçalı
şeyleri alıp götürüyor. Yağmur yağıyor.
Oradaki çamur gibi akıyor ya yağmur
yağdığında onları alıp götürüyor. Biz
buna eroz yont diyoruz. Toprağın üstünün
yontulması. Erozyon budur. Bunu
anladığınızı düşünüyorum. Erozyon.
Erozyont. Toprağın üstünün yontulması.
Bunun tehlikesi ne biliyor musunuz
gençler? Toprağın en verimli kısmı en
üstteki kısmıdır. En üstteki o ince ufak
parçalar oluyor ya toz gibi parçalar
diyelim. Orası toprağın en verimli
kısmıdır. Şimdi sen toprağın üstünü
üstünü yontarsan, erozyont yontarsan
aslında toprağın en verimli kısmını alıp
götürüyorsun. E en verimli kısmını
götürürsen götürdüm toprakta
verimsizleşiyor. Böylece erozyon ortaya
çıkıyor. Erozyon kötü bir şey. Erozyon
toprağı ne yapıyor? Verimsiz hale
getiriyor. Tamam. Erozyon. Erozyon.
Burada eee bir dikkat etmeniz gereken
bir şey var. Bu ne biliyor musunuz?
Erozyon. Erozyon değil bu arada gençler.
Ben hep böyle bazen erozyon diyorum
buna. Erozyon. Bir bakmışsınız bu sene
TYT'de Türkçede çıkmış. Dikkat edin.
Erozyon. Erozyonu biyolojik afetlere
koyuyoruz. Bak burası benim artık
üniversite sınav sorusu olarak
beklediğim soru. Erozyonun biyolojik
afetlere koyulması. Çünkü erozyon nereye
koyacağını bilemiyor öğrenci. Biraz da
klimatolojik, meteorolojik gibi geliyor
ama biyolojiktir. Bana sorsanız neden
hocam biyolojiktir diye. Ben bunun
cevabını aradım, taradım, bulamadım.
Yani neden bunu biyolojik kısma
koyuyorlar kısmını ben bulamadım. Bunu
senin araştırmanı istiyorum. Erozyon
neden biyolojik afettir? Tamam. Niye
buraya koymuşlar? Orman yangınları da
biyolojik. Bakın ya orman yangınlarında
bir sürü ağaç yanıyor. Canlılar,
ormanların içerisindeki canlılar telef
oluyor, bitiyor. Bu mesela biyolojik
afet. Bundan dolayı olabilir. Bunu
anlarım. Mesela salgın çok basit. E
zaten virüslerden çıkıyor ortaya.
Biyolojik bir afet. Bunu anlarsın. Böcek
istelaları kendileri böcek. Biyolojik
canlı. Canlınlığın oluşturduğu afetler
bunlar. Tamam. Bunları koyarsın ama şu
erozyonu kesinlikle unutmuyorsun. Orman
yangınları da nasıl biyolojik afetmiş
demek. Bunu da anladık. Geliyoruz bu
sefer bak beşeri afetlere yani
insanların oluşturduğu afetlere.
Bunlardan bir tanesi sosyal afetler.
Savaş. Sosyal afetlerde bak yangınlara
da insanlar neden oluyor. Yangınların
çoğu gençler insanlar tarafından
çıkartıyor ve biz bunları sosyal afetler
içerisine koyuyoruz. Bak teknolojik
değil sosyal. İnsan ilişkileriyle
insanla ilişkileri kısmıyla biraz düşün
bunu. Göçler sosyal bir afet toplumsal
bir afet. Terör saldırıları. Bunların
hepsi sosyal afetler içerisine giriyor.
Anlaştık mı? Bak bu tarafta bir de
teknoloji diye ayırıyoruz bunu. Ulaşım
teknolojik bir şey değil mi? Evet.
Karayolları en fazla ulaşımda en fazla
insanların can ve mal kaybına neden
olduğu kısım karayolları araçları
gençler. Ulaşım maden kazaları. Mesela
Soma'da kaza olmuştu. 301 madenci
hayatını kaybetmişti. Bu da bir afet ama
nasıl? teknolojik kısmında sanayide
kazaları olabiliyor. Havai fişek e
fabrikası patlamıştı şeyde, Gebzede
mesela böyle düşünün. Biyolojik,
nükleer, kimyasal silahlar, nükleer
kazalar. Bunların hepsi teknolojik
afetler içerisinde. Buradaki mantığı
anladık mı? Tamam. Buradaki afetleri
sana böyle tek anlatmıyorum. O 10. sınıf
konusu ama kabaca da olsa sana
gösterdim. Ama Türkiye'deki kısımları bu
senenin konusu. Bu arada şimdi
Türkiye'deki kısımlarına bakacağız.
Türkiye'deki afetlere gençler ülkemizde
bol miktarda afet yaşanıyor. Şuraya
bakın deprem yaşıyoruz. Daha Silivri'de
oturuyorum ben. Daha geçen hafta
yaşadım. Heyan, su baskınları, çığı,
kuraklık, orman yangınları, fırtına,
hortu, toprak erozyonu. Bunların hepsini
çoğunu yaşıyoruz. Şuradaki tabloyu
inceleyelim. Bakın can kaybının en fazla
yaşandığı afetimiz hangisi? 17.000 kişi.
Bakın, deprem. Bu 1920 ile 2023 yılları
arasındakini kapsıyor. Burada mesela
Kahramanmaraş'takileri koymamışlar.
Mesela 6 Şubat'ta Kahramanmaraş'ta
53.000'e yakın insanımız hayatını
kaybetmişti. Değil mi? Allah rahmet
eylesin diyelim. Şimdi bakın çığ
düşmelerinde bakın yine bayağı var.
Deprem. Depremde şurada Erzincan
depreminde bakın 653 kişi hayatını
kaybetmiş. Bakın yine burada deprem var.
Van depremi 644 kişi. Evet en fazla
şurası. Şuradaki tabloyu bileceğiz.
Gençler, hayatını kaybeden insan oranına
göre düşündüğümüzde en fazla can kaybına
neden olan afet Türkiye'de deprem. En
fazla can kaybı depremde yaşanıyor.
Tamam mı? Ama gerçekleşme oranı
diğerlerini bir kenara bırakırsak
parçalı parçalı onlar yani gerçekleşme
en fazla kütle hareketleri gerçekleşiyor
bizim ülkemizde. Bunun notunu şöyle
yazmanı istiyorum senden. Türkiye'de en
fazla yaşanan afet kütle hareketleridir.
Yani heylan, toprak kayması, kaya
düşmeleri. Bunlar kütle hareketleri. Yaz
böyle. Türkiye'de en fazla yaşanan afet
kütle hareketleridir. Ama bir de şöyle
yaz. Türkiye'de en fazla can kaybına
neden olan afet deprem. Tamam. En fazla
hareketi yaşıyoruz ama onlar bu kadar
can kaybına neden olmuyor. En fazla can
kaybına neden olan afet depremler.
Binlerce insanımızı kaybediyoruz. Bunun
notunu al. Türkiye'de depremlere gelelim
gençler. Bizim ülkemiz Alphimalaya
deprem kuşağındadır. Bakın bu bizim
konumuz bu arada. Bu senenin konusu.
Türkiye'deki afetleri anlatmış. Şöyle
göstereyim size. Bakın şimdi deprem
çizgisini çizmiştik sizinle. Değil mi? E
bu deprem çizgisinde bakın nereden
geçiyor. Nereden geçiyor? Alpimalea
deprem kuşağıdır burası gençler.
Türkiye'de Alpimalea dağ kuşağındadır.
Yani şöyle şeyu Türkiye kısmını kaymış.
Yani Türkiye Alp Himalea deprem kuşağı
içerisinde yer alır. Şöyle şunu unutun.
Altını çizin. Bu kısmı artık sizi
ilgilendiriyor. Türkiye Alpimale deprem
kuşağındadır. Türkiye Avrasya, Afrika ve
Arap levhaları arasında yer alır. Yani
şu gençler, kuzeyde Türkiye'de Avrasya
levhası vardır. Tamam mı? Şurada Afrika
levhası vardır. Şurada da Arabistan
levhası vardır. Türkiye, Avrasya Afrika
ve Arabistan levhalarının arasında yer
alır. Güneyden Afrika ve Arabistan
levhası Türkiye'yi sıkıştırır.
Avrasyaile o arada kalır Türkiye ve fay
hatlarımız oluşur. Hangileri bunlar? Şu
kuzeyden geçen fay hattı. Kaf kaf Kuzey
Anadolu fay hattı. Şu bakın Hatay'dan
ülkemize giren hani Afrika'nın
doğusundan böyle bir kırık vardı ya
ülkemizde birleşiyor demiştik. Şu DAF
Doğu Anadolu fay hattı. Şuralarda da
kırık kırık fay hatlarımız var. Batı
Anadolu fay hattı. BAF. Bakın
Türkiye'nin birçok e yeri deprem
kuşağında. Yani Türkiye deprem
bölgesidir gençler. Bunu unutmuyorsunuz.
Bakın kaçı? %92'si. Peki Türkiye'de
nasıl depremler görülüyor? Bunun altını
çiz. En fazla tektonik deprem görülür
gençler Türkiye'de. Tektonik deprem
demek gücünü yerin altından alan
depremler demek. Tektonik deprem görülür
en fazla Türkiye'de. Bunun dışında bakın
volkanik depremlere çok fazla
rastlamıyoruz. Neden? Çünkü ülkemiz
aktif volkanların olduğu bir yer değil.
Volkan patlaması olacak ki çevresinde
deprem olsun. O yüzden volkanik
depremlere pek rastlamıyoruz. Peki hocam
ülkemizde çöküntü depremleri var mı? Var
ama çok fazla etkilemiyor bizi. Nerede
oluyor biliyor musunuz çöküntü
depremleri? Çöküntü olması için kalkerli
kireçli bir arazi lazım. Lazım bize.
Karstik arazi de Akdeniz'de var. Çöküntü
depremlerine karstik arazinin olduğu
Akdeniz'de rastlayabiliyoruz. Özellikle
şu bölgede. Tamam ama çok rastlamıyoruz.
Yani Türkiye'de en fazla depremler nasıl
oluşuyormuş? Bunun notunu alıyorsun.
Yıldız atıyorsun. Çöküntü depremleriyle
pardon as yanlış söylüyordum. Tektonik
depremlerle oluşuyormuş. Tamam bir not
daha aldık. Türkiye'de Türkiye Alpimale
deprem kuşağında bulunur. Bir not daha
aldık. Türkiye'nin %92'si deprem bölgesi
içerisinde yer alır. Bakın Kahramanmaraş
Pazarcık depremi 7.7 ve 7.6 büyüklüğünde
olmuştu. 53.000'e yakın insanımız
hayatını kaybetmişti. Peki hocam
Türkiye'de heylan nasıl yaşanır?
Türkiye'de heylanın görüldüğü bölgeler
heylan gelme dağın yarısı kopup gelecek.
Eğimli bir arazi lazım bize. Artı suya
şişecek. Şişecek. Şişecek. E nerede var
eğimli arazi ve suyun olduğu en fazla?
Karadeniz'de var. Özellikle şu Doğu
Karadeniz gençler ve Kastamonu şu bölge
heyın en fazla olduğu yer. Ama bunlara
Erzurum'u da ekleyeceğiz. Tamam mı?
Biraz daha iç kısma, doğu kısmına doğru
da hafif hafif heylan yaşanabiliyor. O
bölgelerde dağlık engebeli olduğu için.
Heylan denildiğinde, heylan denildiğinde
nasıl? Şurada Karadeniz dağlık suyu 77
yedi. Kaydı Erzurum'u da içine alacağız.
Anlaştık mı? HLA'nın bulunduğu Türkiye
haritası da bu. Türkiye'de eroz yont.
Toprak yontulacak. Toprağın
yontulabilmesi için toprağın üstünün
çıplak olması gerekiyor. Kurak, yarı
kurak bir yer olması gerekiyor. Bitki
örtüsü olmayacak. Toprak örtüsü bakın
kurak yarı kurak bir bölge olacak. Bitki
örtüsü tahrip edilmiş. Bakın kurak yarı
kurak bir arazi. Eğimli olursa daha
güzel kayar toprak. Ama ana püf nokta
ne? Kurak yarı kurak olacak. Nerede
görülüyor? Bakın yüksek kırmızı
kahverengi. Görüyor musunuz? E kurak,
yarı kurak, çöl gibi olan yer neresi? İç
kısımlar. Güneydoğu Anadolu kısmı ve
bakın yine dağlık bölgelerde hafif hafif
yine var ama en çok neresi diye eee
yaparsak iç bölge şurası. Erozyont
Güneydoğu Anadolu. Bu bölge gençler
kurak, yarı kurak çöl gibi. O zaman
burada toprak çok rahatla aşınıp
taşınıyor. Bak buralar ne? Erozyont.
Erozyont. Türkiye'nin birçok kısmı
erozyona maruz kalır. En şiddetlisini
gösterdim size. Burası ne? Erozyont.
Heyelan neredeydi hocam? Heylan'ı şöyle
kırmızı alayım size. Heylan şurada
Kastamonu civarında. Doğu Karadeniz
şurada Erzurum civarındaydı. Gördük mü?
Eroz yont olabilmesi için. Toprağın
yontulabilmesi için kurak yarı kurak bit
örtüsünün olmadığı yer olacak. Hey lan
dağın kopup gelecek. Hem eğimli hem de
yağmur yağacak. Türkiye'de sel ve
taşkınlar nerede gençler? Şehirleşmenin
çok olduğu bölgelerde yaşanıyor sel ve
taşkınlar. Bakın Ankara'da var. Evet. E
şurada yine Karadeniz'in bulunduğu
bölgelerde yağmurlar çok fazla olduğu
için Karadeniz'de Doğu Anadolu'da sev
taşkınlar çok yaşanabiliyor burada.
Çünkü sadece yağışın bol olduğu gibi
düşünmeyelim. Kar erimeleri, karların
erimeleri burada çok etkili. O yüzden
zaten şunun notunu alın. Sevde taşkınlar
Nisan, Mayıs ve Haziran aylarında çok
şiddetleniyor. Ne zaman oluyor Sevlet
Taşkınlar? Nisan, Mayıs, Haziran. Bunlar
karın eridiği zamanlar. Karın eridiği bu
zamanlar. Özellikle kar nerede eriyor?
Bakın doğu kısımda şurada eriyecek kar.
E o zaman Erzurum, Ağrı, Bingöl bu
bölgelerde sel ve taşkınlar yaşanıyor.
Bakın Karadeniz'de yağış olduğu için
Giresun'da yaşanıyor. Evet. Evet.
Ankara'da niye yaşanıyor? Çünkü Ankara
büyükşehir. Büyükşehirlerde de Selda
taşkınlara betonlaşmadan dolayı
rastlıyoruz. Tamam. Çığı nerede? Çığ
için bize dağlık engebeli bir yer lazım.
Şu harita çalışmasını yapmamız yetiyor
bizim için bu konuda. Çığı dağlık
engebeli bir yer lazım bize. Çünkü
dağlık yerde kar yağacak. Kar yağması
lazım. E Doğu Anadolu'da yağmıyor mu kar
gençler? Çığ üçgeni diyorum ben buna. Şu
bölgeyi şöyle işaretliyorsunuz. En fazla
çığın olduğu yer şu bölge. Bakın şöyle
şöyle. Tunceli Bingöl şuradan Bitliy
Hakkari civarına. Çığ çığ üçgeni bu
benim için. Tamam. Çığ için şuraya tik
atıyorum ben. Hep şöyle çığ çığ v'si. Bu
nasıl? Çığ tiki diyorum ben buna. Tamam.
Doğu kısmında çığa rastlayacağız yani.
Anlaştık mı? Peki hocam orman
yangınlarına nerede rastlayacağız? E
orman yangını Akdeniz ikliminde oluyor.
Sıcak olacak, kurak olacak, orman
olacak. E ne olacak? Akdeniz'in
Akdeniz'in bulunduğu bu bölgede orman
yangınlarına daha çok Akdeniz kısmında
rastlayacağız. Anlaştık mı? Evet. Evet.
Şimdi iki tane kısım öğrendik. Ne
yaptık? Afetleri tabloya yerleştirmeyi
öğrendik. Türkiye'deki afetlerin harita
çalışmasını yaptık. Bunu istiyor bizden
Milli Eğitim. Ve tehlike, risk, afet
nedir? Bunu öğrendik. Şimdi dördüncü ve
son olarak bizden istediği bir şey var.
Şunu bileceksin diyor. Nedir bu? Yani
şunu bileceksin diyor bize. Eee, risk
yönetimi ve kriz yönetimi. Yani önce ne
yapmamız lazım? Ya depremler oluyor,
afetler yaşanıyor. Birçok afet
yaşanıyor. Ama bu afetler yaşanırken
yaşanmadan önce, yaşanm, yaşandıktan
sonra, yaşanma anında risk yönetimi
neler yapmamız gerekiyor bizim gençler?
Bakın, ilk olarak önlem alınması
gerekiyor. Bu tablonun birinci aşaması
budur. Tamam mı? Bu diyagramı bilmemiz
lazım. Nedir bu? Önlem alınması
gerekiyor önce. Yani risk ve zararı
azaltma deniyor buna. Risk ve zararı
azaltma. Birinci kısım sana. Risk ve
zararı azaltma denildiğinde ab bu bir
demen lazım. Burada da ne var? Önlemler
var. Önlemlerden kastımız aslında
devletin yasalar koyması. Devlet yasalar
koyacak ki insanlar otellere yangın
söndürme şeyleri yapsınlar. Tamam mı?
Eee, devlet bu yasalarla beraber o
oteller yapılırken yangın söndürme,
yangın merdivenleri, yangın söndürme
sistemleri bunlar önlem kısmına giriyor
işte. Tamam. Yani ne yapıyorsun sen?
Risk ve zararı azaltmış oluyorsun. Diğer
sonra ikinci aşamaya geçiliyor. İkinci
aşama tahmin ve erken uyarı. Yani
hazırlıklı olma kısmı. Şu kısım bakın.
Hazırlıklı olma kısmı. Ne yaptık? Risk
yönetimi kısmını ele aldık. Risk ve
zararı azaltma önlem dedik. Sonra
hazırlıklı olma. İkinci kısma geçtik. Bu
da tahmin ve erken uyarı. Ne yapacağız
burada? Bak erken uyarı sistemlerini
kuracağız. Buna böyle yazın. Hazırlıklı
olma kısmına erken uyarı sistemi yazın.
Bu bizim için çok önemli. Mesela
toplanma merkezlerinin belirlenmesi
lazım. Önceden acil eylem planlarını
yapmamız gerekiyor. İşte ihtiyaç
duyulabilecek afet olduğunda ihtiyaç
duyabilecek malzemelerin belirlenmesi
gerekiyor. Şimdi ne yaptık biz? Şu ikisi
gençler ne yaptık? Bir risk ve zarar
azaltma dedik. 1 sonra 2 hazır olma
dedik. Bu ikisini biz risk yönetimi
olarak adlandırıyoruz. Yani şu ikisinin
şu üst kısmına risk yönetimi diyorum.
Şöyle. Tamam mı? Burası risk
yönetimimiz. İkinci kısımda kriz
yönetimi. Bu sefer bir kriz ortaya
çıkıyor. Kriz yönetimi yani şu. Şurayı
ikiye böldük biz. Tamam mı? Üst kısmı
risk yönetimi, alt kısmı kriz yönetimi.
Risk yönetimi. Daha ortaya bir şey
çıkmamış. Daha afet yaşanmamış. Afet
yaşanmadan önce birinci olarak risk ve
zararı azaltmak için devlet önlem önlem
alıyor, kurallar koyuyor. Sonra ikinci
olarak tahmin ve erken uyarı sistemleri
kuruyor. Hazır oluyoruz. Hazır olma
kısmına geçiyoruz. Erken uyarı
sistemleri kuruyoruz. Hazırlıklı bir
pozisyona geçiyoruz. Tamam. Sonra artık
afet yaşanıyor. Kriz yönetimi kısmına
geçiyoruz. Bu sefer müdahale kısmına
geçiyoruz. Şöyle. Bu da 3.cü aşamamız.
Müdahale edeceğiz afeti. Afet yaşandı.
Yani şuradayız. Hızlıca hasar tespiti
yaptık. Enkazların kaldırılmasıyla
oluşabilecek yangınlar, patlamalar,
salgın hastalıklar yani e afet yaşandı
ve hızlıca müdahale ettik. Bu sefer
arama kurtarma yaptık. Bakın gittik
oraya. Barınma, ilaç, güvenlik yardımı
yaptık. Afet yaşandı. Bütün
yardımlarımızı yaptık. Buna da ne dedik?
Müdahale dedik. Bu 3üncü aşama. Sonra
bir de 4üncü aşama geliyor. Bu sefer
iyileştirme yapacağız. Artık deprem
bitmiş. İyileştirme yapmamız lazım. Şu
an mesela Kahramanmaraş için iyileştirme
aşamasındayız. Ne yapıyoruz? Evler
yapılmaya çalışılıyor değil mi o
bölgede? O bölge iyileştirilmeye
çalışılıyor. 4.üncü aşama. Şimdi şöyle
başa alalım. Tamam mı? İlk olarak iki
tane aşamamız var. Bunlardan bir tanesi
risk yönetimi. Diğeri pardon niye sildim
ben bunu ya? Kriz yönetimi. Risk
yönetiminde afet ortaya çıkmamış. Önce
ne yapıyoruz biz? Yasa koyuyoruz. Riski
ve zarar azaltma kısmını yapıyoruz.
Sonra hazır olma kısmı yapıyoruz. Burada
da erken uyarı sistemlerimiz var. Sonra
afet ortaya çıkıyor. Şöyle birinci
aşama, ikinci aşama, 3üncü aşama afet
ortaya çıkıyor. Bu sefer ne yapıyoruz?
Müdahale ediyoruz. Ve 4üncü aşamada da
iyileştirme yapıyoruz. Bunlar afetlerle
risk yönetimi, kriz yönetimi yani
bütüncül afet yönetimi dediğimiz şey. Bu
senin 4.üncü sorun. Afetlerle alakalı
önemli olan kısma kısım burası. Afetler
ve savunmasız kısı gruplardan kastı
gençler afetlerde anneler, kadınlar,
çocuklar önceliklidir. Yaşlılar
öncelidir. Bunu kastediyor burada.
Mekansal ve bilgi teknolojileriyle
afetilerden kastı da şu. CBS dediğimiz
bir şey vardı. Bunu öğrenmiştik
hatırlayın. 9. sınıfta başlarda. Bu CPS
ile beraber verileri alıp afetlerle
alakalı nerede nasıl oluşmuş? Bu yerin
topografyası nasıl? Bu yerin coğrafi
bilgilerini öğreniyoruz. Bu konu bize
buraya önlem almamız noktasında yardımcı
oluyor. Deprem anında da bilgileri
almamızı sağlıyor. Sonrasında oluşacak
şeyleri bu verilere CBS'ye aktarıyoruz.
Yani mekansal bilgi teknolojileriyle
afetleri bir bütüncül halinde
kullandığımız zaman öncesinde de işimize
yarıyor bu mekan teknoloji kısmı.
Yaşanırken de sonrasında da işimize
yarıyor. Buradaki mantık da bu.
Uluslararası yardımlar ve afetler.
Afetler yaşandığında uluslararası
yardımlar geliyor. Mesela
Kahramanmaraş'ta birçok dünyadan birçok
insan bize yardım etmişti. Birçok ülke.
Biz de aynı şekilde dünyaya afet
yaşandığında yardıma gidiyoruz kısmı.
Bunu da tamamladık. O zaman Zeduava
öğretmenleri olarak artık afetler
kısmını da bitirmiş olduk. Evet gençler
bunu da bitirmiş olduk. Afetler kısmı
bitti. Bundan sonra bölgeler kısmı
kaldı. Bölgeleri de halledeceğiz
inşallah beraber. Gençler bakın
PDF'inizi renkli bir şekilde
alıyorsunuz. Videolarınız ücretsiz bir
şekilde sunuluyor size. Bunları size
parayla satıyorlar. Bakın parayla
alıyorsunuz. Bu videolar parayla
veriliyor size. Rica ediyorum sizden.
İstirham ediyorum sizden. Abone olun.
Hevesimiz kaçmasın. Böyle şevkli bir
şekilde çalışıyoruz. Zedova
öğretmenlerine abone olarak destek olun
lütfen. Bunca videoyu ücretsiz sunuyoruz
size. Seviliyorsunuz gençler bu dersi de
öğrendik. Ne diyoruz o zaman? Yunus
hocayla bir defa öğren. Bir daha asla
unutma. Bir sonraki derste görüşmek
üzere.